ce matin comme vous le savez nous
poursuivons les les l'examen des
missions d'information
qui s'inscrivent on va dire dans la
perspective de la prochaine loi de
programmation militaire comme vous le
savez les missions d'information
concernant les fonds marins de la
préparation opérationnelle nous ont été
présentés la semaine dernière ce seront
des thématiques clés de la LPM
d'ailleurs comme la défense solaire les
stocks de munitions qui feront l'objet
d'une présentation ce jour cependant
pour bien préparer la LPM on a besoin
également d'une vision globale et
notamment de tirer les leçons de
l'exécution de l'actuel loi
programmation militaire pour certains
qui sont ici qui sont souvenaient qu'on
avait voté en 2018 et qui couvrait qui
couvre puisque c'est l'autre
programmation actuelle la période
2019-2025 quel jugement portait sur
cette LPM sur son exécution et qu'elle
enseignement en tiré pour la prochaine
LPM c'est deux questions ont guidé les
travaux de nos deux rapporteurs nos deux
collègues Yannick funvar et Laurent
jacobelli de la mission d'information
sur le bilan de la LPM 2019-2025
mission longue aux côtés des quatre
missions flash que je vous ai dont je
vous ai parlé précédemment mission
longue au regard de la diversité des
enjeux je rappelle que cette mission
d'information inclut également comme
membre Jean-Michel Jacques Fabien Lainé
Jean-Charles larseneur pierre muret
lahuissier et Isabelle Santiago alors
nous avons 4 heures ce matin 9h à 13h et
concernant l'organisation de notre temps
je vous propose de consacrer 1h40 à
l'examen de la bilan du bilan de la LPM
et une Nordiste pour chacun des deux
missions flash qui suivront et je
m'installe moi-même à faire court sans
plus tarder messieurs les rapporteur je
vous laisse la parole
merci monsieur le président
mes chers collègues c'est le Président
je vous remercie
pour vos propos introductifs je remercie
également la commission nous avoir
confié la conduite de cette mission sur
le bilan de la FPM qui a été
passionnante Laurent jacobelli et
moi-même sommes ravis de pouvoir vous
présenter aujourd'hui les conclusions de
notre travaux je souhaite d'ailleurs
associer à mes remerciements et sans
doute Laurent jacobelli avec moi les
administrateurs ne se nicodo monsieur
imourat puis je voudrais également de
manière très personnelle remercier mon
équipe qui est présente l'ensemble de
mes collaborateurs nous avons tous
travaillé en vaillant équipage
prévoir pour pourvoir afin de pouvoir
cette phrase de du Maréchal Foch n'a pas
pris une ride mais votre programmation
militaire est une loi singulière elle
constitue tout d'abord l'incarnation du
pacte entre la nation et son armée elle
est également un outil de planification
financière indispensable pour nos armées
dont les programmes d'équipements
s'inscrivent dans le temps long cette
notion tendon si difficile à promouvoir
à une époque où le cours termisme prend
souvent l'ascendant sur la préparation
de l'avenir est en matière de
programmation militaire fondamentale
il est de notre responsabilité de voir
loin bien au-delà de nos petites
personnes nous servons quelque chose de
bien plus grand la nation
une autre programmation militaire est
avant tout la traduction d'une ambition
stratégique elle symbolise plus que tout
autre loi la place que notre pays
souhaite tenir au sein du concert des
nations des grandes nations
malheureusement
les précédentes LP m'ont surtout traduit
une perte d'ambition
revenons à cet égard sur le contexte
dont a hérité la LPM 2019-2025
premièrement un budget de la défense
sacrifié sur l'Hôtel des dividendes de
la paix aucune des précédentes LPM mes
chers collègues je dis bien aucune n'a
été respecté dans cette trajectoire
financière depuis le début des années 80
autrement dit nos armées ont servi
unlassablement de variables d'ajustement
budgétaire pendant 40 ans deuxièmement
c'est la conséquence de ce qui précède
la LPM 19 25 a hérité d'armée
durablement affaiblie par ses décennies
de sous-investissement
quelques chiffres pour illustrer
l'ampleur des dégâts causés par ces
fameux dividendes de la paix réduction
des effectifs de 2008 à 2019 le mystère
des armées a perdu plus de 63000 emplois
soit plus de 20% de ses effectifs cette
déflation ayant cependant pris fin en
avec le renforcement de la Force
opérationnelle terrestre dans le cadre
de l'opération sentinelle réduction de
nos capacités le parc d'aéronef de
l'armée de l'air à diminué de 139% 139%
depuis 1990 le nombre de chars est passé
de 1349 en 1991 à 222 en 2021 le nombre
de bâtiments de combat est passé pour la
marine et passer de 135 en 1990 à 85 en
réduction de nos contrats opérationnels
en 1997 il est très prévu l'engagement
de 50000 militaires dans une opération
de coercition majeur depuis 2014 il
n'est plus prévu que le déplacement le
déploiement pardon de 15000 soldats dans
le cadre d'un tel engagement
troisième élément
ce contexte dont a hérité la LPM c'est
l'accroissement des menaces telles que
mis en lumière par la regie stratégique
en 2017
menace du terrorisme islamique bien sûr
encore
pondérante pardon à l'époque mais de
toute façon toujours d'actualité
retour des logiques de puissance les
empires qui sont de retour avec un
réarmement croissant des compétiteurs
stratégiques et des puissances
régionales et ben nous y sommes au final
nos armées en 2017 devaient faire face à
des tendances contradictoires une
déflation des effectifs et les moyens et
parallèlement un engagement constant
voire croissant en opération extérieure
comme d'ailleurs sur le territoire
national évidemment
poursuivre dans une telle voie n'était
plus tenable le choix de la LPM fut de
marquer une rupture franche nette avec
cette dynamique déflationniste dans le
prolongement des efforts initiés dès
le rappel de ce contexte permet de
comprendre l'objectif principal de la
LPM 19 25 c'est une loi de réparation il
s'agit en fait de réparer nos amis nos
armées abîmées
abîmés par des décennies de
sous-investissement
le rappel de ce contexte permet
également de mesurer l'ampleur de
l'effort de redressement qui est amené
et mené dans la durée car il faut de la
durée en matière militaire en matière
d'équipement c'est à ce titre que la LPM
2019-2025 est structuré autour de
l'ambition 2030 que vous connaissez par
cœur mes chers collègues ambition 2030
c'est la construction d'un modèle
d'armée complet et équilibré
pour agir sur l'ensemble du spectre à
l'horizon 2030 cette ambition prend de
forme premièrement la fixation de
contrat opérationnel à respecter avec la
définition des formats et capacités
employés en fonction des missions
deuxièmement la fixation d'une cible
d'équipement à atteindre en 2030 avec un
jalon en 2025
la LPM fixait ainsi une trajectoire de
remontée en puissance en deux temps une
phase de réparation nous y sommes
jusqu'en 2023 suivi d'une phase de
modernisation jusqu'en 2030 autrement
dit et vraiment je me permets d'insister
sur ce point
évaluer l'exécution de la LPM de 2019 a
aujourd'hui c'est en vérité dresser le
bilan du début de cette phase de
redressement qui doit s'achever à
l'horizon 2030 cette ambition
opérationnelle est portée par un effort
financier majeur près de 300 milliards
d'euros 295 très précisément de 2019 à
2025 avec l'objectif de porter l'effort
de défense à hauteur de 2% du PIB en 25
cela correspond à une augmentation de
ressources de 23%
. cet effort financier était doublé
d'une sincérisation des ressources à
travers deux mécanismes l'absence de
prévision de recherche exceptionnelle
d'une part et d'autre part
l'augmentation conséquente de la
provision OPEX pour leur rapprocher de
son courriel
merci beaucoup
bien sûr je voudrais m'associer moi
aussi remerciements qui ont été
effectués
sa mi Moura et Aurélien nicodeau qui
sont nos administrateurs qui ont fait je
dois le dire un travail d'une précision
d'une exactitude et d'une minutie
exemplaire tous les membres de la
commission et tous les civils et les
militaires qui ont bien voulu nous
accorder leur temps pour répondre à nos
questions parfois un peu
un peu un peu poussé mais en général
cela s'est fait sans langue de bois et
avec beaucoup de beaucoup de franchises
parce que je crois que tout le monde
avait intérêt à ce que le bilan soit le
plus précis possible pour que nous
préparions l'avenir et la prochaine LPM
avec des éléments concrets et des jalons
qui puissent nous aider tu as très bien
décrit les objectifs de cette LPM cette
loi de réparation comme on l'a appelé je
pense qu'il faut maintenant aller dans
l'analyse de l'exécution de cette LPM et
c'est ce que je vais faire maintenant
avec vous et je vais commencer
d'ailleurs par les bonnes nouvelles vous
verrez qu'on a essayé avec franchise de
montrer ce qu'il y avait fonctionné un
peu moins fonctionné et nous allons en
faire le tour tous ensemble le premier
constat et je pense que vous le savez
déjà c'est que cette l'aspect
programmation financière a été respectée
à l'euro près et c'est vrai tu l'as
évoqué c'est une première depuis 40 ans
il faut il faut le reconnaître les
marches de 1,7 milliards d'euros puis de
3 milliards d'euros en 2023 ont été
franchis c'est vrai qu'on pouvait en
douter même dans les états majors
d'ailleurs et parfois les politiques
aussi mais il faut le reconnaître les
chiffres ont été respectés cette
conformité est double les lois de
finances initiales ont ouvert chaque
année des conformes à la LPM et les
crédits ouverts ont eux-mêmes été
consommés totalement à exécution grâce à
cette exécution de la programmation
financière
le budget de la mission défense a ainsi
augmenté de 28% en 2018 soit prêt de 10
milliards d'euros par an c'est vrai
c'est vrai qu'on venait de loin mais
c'était une étape nécessaire voir vitale
pour nos forces armées alors la question
est comment cet effort financier majeur
a été alloué et bien conformément en
prévision de la LPM ce sont les
équipements de nos armées qui ont
bénéficié prioritairement de ces
augmentations budgétaires les crédits
dédiés alors au plus grand programme
d'équipements ce qu'on appelle les PEM
programme AFP majeurs ont ainsi augmenté
de plus de 49% entre 2018 et 2023 il est
vrai qu'il a fallu reconstituer un stock
on va dire qu'il y avait été très
malmené cet effort en faveur des
équipements doit d'autant plus être
remarqué souligné que ces derniers ont
traditionnellement été les premiers
touchés par les ajustements budgétaires
passés ce qui a donné lieu à des
étalement de programme particulièrement
coûteux pour nos permet mais aussi pour
nos finances publiques et je pense
notamment au programme des frames
les autres segments qui ont bénéficié
prioritairement de l'augmentation des
crédits sont et je vais vous les
énumérer dans l'ordre la dissuasion le
maintien en conditions opérationnelles
puis les infrastructures
ce respect de la trajectoire financière
globale fixée par la LPM ne signifie pas
ne signifie pas bien évidemment que tout
s'est passé comme prévu c'est l'ordre
naturel des choses tous ceux qui ont
déjà fait des budgets dans leur vie le
savent ça évolue sa vie c'est une
matière malléable si la LPM a pour
vocation de sécuriser les ressources
évidemment elle n'a pas pour but de
graver les dépenses dans le marbre comme
la mentionné un des une des
personnalités auditionnées la
programmation militaire est un organisme
vivant ce qu'elle doit s'adapter à
l'évolution du contexte stratégique
économique et à la vie des programmes
qu'elle finance en l'espèce c'est un peu
plus d'un milliard d'euros chaque année
qui ont fait l'objet d'ajustement
c'est-à-dire qui ont été redéployés en
cours d'exécution
un milliard d'euros par an c'est
beaucoup évidemment en valeur absolue et
au regard du budget total de la mission
défense ça reste à la marge ces
ajustements ont été dictées tout d'abord
par des inflexions capacitaires décidées
pour tenir compte de l'évolution des
défis auxquels font face aux armées une
forme d'adaptabilité nécessaire
à titre d'exemple l'ajustement annuel de
2019 s'est traduit par une hausse des
moyens consacrés à l'espace dans le
prolongement de la stratégie spatiale de
défense publier la même année avec la
création d'un programme de maîtrise de
l'espace
autre exemple
à la suite de l'actualisation de la
revue stratégique de 2021 qui a insisté
sur le retour de la compétition entre
puissance et la généralisation des
stratégies hybrides l'actualisation de
la LPM aboutit à un effort d'un milliard
d'euros une fois encore au bénéfice des
priorités suivantes le renseignement et
le cyber à hauteur de d'un tiers de
cette somme les domaines santé NRBC et
lutte antidrone pour 210 millions
d'euros et les moyens dédiés à la
préparation opérationnelle pour 450
millions d'euros
outre l'adaptation au contexte
stratégique la programmation a dû
également s'adapter à l'évolution du
contexte économique la période de 2019 à
2021 a connu une évolution plus faible
que prévu du coup des facteurs ce qui a
engendré un gain d'environ 400 millions
d'euros de pouvoir d'achat du ministère
des armées qui ont permis de financer
certains ajustements
un contrario et ce sera pas une surprise
pour vous parce que ce phénomène touche
tous les secteurs de l'activité de notre
pays le retournement de la conjoncture à
compter de 2022 avec le retour terrible
de l'inflation a créé des besoins de
financement estimés à un milliard
d'euros par le ministère pour l'année
2023 qui devrait notamment être absorbé
par une dégradation du report des
charges
enfin la programmation a également dû
faire face à certains surcoût résultant
d'aléas mais là aussi c'est la loi du
genre les principales sources de surcoût
que nous avons identifié avec mon
collègue Cora porteur sont les suivantes
tout d'abord les opérations OPEX MI5
l'augmentation de la provision à 1,1
milliard d'euros n'a en effet pas été
suffisante pour couvrir l'ensemble des
coûts le ministère a ainsi financé seul
j'insiste bien nous en parlerons 846
millions d'euros de surcounet de 2019 à
2021 à travers notamment sa réserve de
précaution
deuxièmement là encore vous le savez
c'est la guerre en Ukraine alors
juridiquement ce n'est pas une OPEX mais
le coût du déploiement de nos armées sur
le flanc Est de l'Europe est estimé à
666 millions d'euros en 2022 pour le
seul programme 178 il convient de
souligner que ce montant n'intègre pas
le coût du recomplissement des matériels
CD à l'Ukraine là aussi c'est un point
que nous évoque
troisièmement les conséquences de la
session de 24 rafales d'occasion à la
Grèce et à la Croatie le produit de
cette session c'est-à-dire le prix de
vente ce qui nous a rapporté c'est
d'environ 656 millions d'euros mais lors
des auditions devant notre commission le
major général de l'armée de l'Air et de
l'Espace avait estimé que la commande de
12 rafales
représentait plus d'un milliard d'euros
par conséquent le coût du recr
complètement de 24 à Falls
représenterait plus de 2 milliards
d'euros cela fait donc un surcoût prix
d'achat ou un prix de vente d'un 3
milliards d'euros au minimum nous nous
avons estimé cela plutôt à 1,7 milliards
suite à nos entretiens
quatrième source de surcoût c'est la
crise liée au covid à la covid pardon
qui a généré plus d'un milliard d'euros
de dépenses supplémentaires non prévus
et pour cause en 2020
cependant celle-ci il faut souligner ont
été entièrement financés par des
moindres dépenses du notamment au
décalage de certaines livraisons enfin
au titre des autres sources de surcoût
non prévues lors du vote de la LPM il
peut être cité la revalorisation
indiciaire pour un montant de 357
millions d'euros par an
au final c'est surtout ont été gérés de
manière relativement souple je dirais
même habile à crédit constante de 2019 à
2021 grâce à une évolution positive du
coût des facteurs à une maîtrise de la
masse salariale et au réajustement
calendaires de certains programmes
en revanche en 2022 le retournement du
contexte économique avec cette inflation
que nous avons évoquée et l'évolution
stratégique et là je pense à nouveau à
l'Ukraine on nécessitait un besoin de
financement d'ampleur qui ne pouvait
être pris en charge par de simples
redéploiements internes sans mettre en
péril cette ambition 2030 que tu nous as
décrit c'est la raison pour laquelle la
loi de finance rectificative de décembre
2022 a ouvert 1,2 milliards d'euros de
crédit au bénéfice de la mission de
défense
cette exécution la programmation
financière appelle en outre un point de
vigilance sur l'évolution des restes à
payer c'est-à-dire des dépenses engagées
mais non encore payées en raison de
l'étalement dans le temps des programmes
d'armement
si j'insiste c'est que ces restes à
payer ont un effet fortement ont en
effet pardon fortement augmenté en
passant de 54 à 83 milliards d'euros de
2019 à 2022
il s'agit bien sûr de la conséquence
logique de l'ambition capacitaire de la
LPM mais cette évolution introduit une
forme de rigidification du budget si on
peut l'appeler comme ça de nos armées
les nouvelles marches ont de plus en
plus vocations à financer les
engagements passés plutôt qu'à initier
de nouveaux engagements dans ces
conditions quelles leçons mes chers
collègues tirés d'exécution de la
programmation financière pour la
prochaine et le PM parce que c'est
évidemment ceux aussi pourquoi nous
sommes réunis aujourd'hui
tout d'abord au vu de l'évolution du
contexte économique il nous faudra être
très attentif à la sécurisation des
ressources de la prochaine LPM le
ministre des Armées je crois à cette
tribune d'ailleurs à évaluer cette
impact de l'inflation à 30 milliards
d'euros sur la période 2024-2030 quid si
l'inflation est supérieure à cette
estimation il serait selon nous
intéressons de réfléchir à un mécanisme
qui permettrait d'ajuster les crédits en
fonction de la variation de l'inflation
réelle par rapport à l'inflation
anticipée afin d'éviter avoir d'avoir à
se reposer comme ce fut le cas en 2022
la question
de finances incertaine tant dans le
principe que dans les montants
au titre de la sécurisation des
ressources il conviendra également
d'être attentif à la nature des 13
milliards d'euros de ressources
exceptionnelles annoncées dans la
prochaine LPM à nouveau que se
passerait-il si ces recettes ne se
réalisent pas comme prévues comme cela a
du reste été le cas lors des précédentes
LPM un mécanisme d'ajustement
automatique avec un abondement crédit
serait là encore le bienvenu
deuxième proposition de notre part il
conviendra que la prochaine LPM dispose
expressément que l'actualisation prenne
la forme d'un vote du Parlement pour
éviter que soit réédité le précédent
fâcheux de 2021 au surplus au vu de
l'ampleur des ajustements annuels on a
évoqué tout à l'heure à une moyenne d'un
milliard par an il semble que le
Parlement pourrait être ou devrait être
davantage associé aux travaux
aboutissants à de tels ajustements sous
un format à déterminer
enfin troisième et dernière proposition
de notre part sur l'exécution de la
programmation financière la prochaine
LPM devra assurer un financement
interministériel systématique
systématique des surcoûts OPEX missent
il n'est pas normal selon nous que le
ministère de la Défense finance seule
les conséquences de choix qui engagent
la nation tout entière par ailleurs
cette provision pourrait utilement être
élargie à d'autres opérations qui ne
sont pas juridiquement des OPEX tel par
exemple que les engagements que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui sur le flanc Est
on remarque donc que si l'exécution
budgétaire de cette LPM a pu être
exécuté à l'euro près ce fut parfois au
prix de
de voltige budgétaire qui sont tout à
fait explicables ce que nous proposons
nous c'est de garantir un cadre beaucoup
plus sûr beaucoup plus tranquille pour
que nos armées puissent investir
déployer ces investissements en toute
sécurité financière
pour ce qui concerne l'exécution du
programme d'équipement qui est prévu par
la LPM cette dernière porte d'abord une
forte ambition de renouvellement de
notre force de dissuasion les crédits
progressent de 44% entre 2018 et 2023 la
nature de ce renouvellement d'ailleurs
était très très largement analysé lors
du cycle d'audition sur le président qui
était consacré à la dissuasion son
programme prévisionnel est donc respecté
la dissuasion sera nécessairement une
composante importante de la future LPM
avec les travaux sur les sous-marins
nucléaires lanceurs d'engins troisième
génération et le futur missile de la
composante aéroportée horizon 2035 la SM
4G
s'agissant des programmes conventionnels
la modernisation elle aussi est en route
pour l'armée de terre elle est
concentrée sur le segment médian le
programme scorpion apporte une véritable
plus value opérationnelle des véhicules
mieux protégés plus mobiles plus
agressif progressivement interconnecté
au sein de la fameuse bulle scorpion
objectif
disposer d'une brigade inter armée
scorpion 2023 cet objectif sera
vraisemblablement tenu avec la montée en
puissance à venir des véhicules Jaguar
et Serval
nous l'avons constaté à carpian au sein
du premier REC ces véhicules
représentent un saut qualitatif
considérable par rapport à la génération
actuelle quand je dis génération
actuelle en fait on peut parler d'une
génération qui a une bonne quarantaine
d'années pour l'armée de mer et de
l'espace les livraisons des avions
ravitailleurs à 330 MRTT et de l'avion
de transport à 400m constitue un
véritable saut opérationnel les
capacités de projection de nos aviateurs
sont démultipliées comme l'illustre les
récentes missions en Indo-Pacifique
mission exceptionnelle que rare
quelques rares puissances sont en
capacité de faire c'était vraiment
exceptionnel pour ce qui concerne la
marine l'action combinée des sous-marins
nucléaires d'attaque programme Barracuda
des frênes et des avions de patrouille
maritimes les atlantiques 2 c'est vrai
qu'il y en a qui sont en rénovation
standard 6 donne toute satisfaction dans
le cadre des opérations de lutte anti
sous-marine on peut d'ailleurs souligner
la récente distinction de nos chasseurs
de ceux qui font de la lutte ASM dans la
marine puisqu'en fait ils ont reçu un
prix exceptionnel qui est un prix qui
classe en fait de façon
opérationnelle les marines dans la lutte
sm on est la première puissance dans ce
domaine là classement américain première
puissance dans ce domaine là c'est
important de le souligner outre ces
programmes ces programmes emblématiques
la LPM a également réalisé un très gros
effort au profit des petits équipements
des équipements du quotidien
la liste des matériels en cours de
renouvellement est très variée gilet
pare-balles fusil d'assaut fusil de
précision pistolet jumelles de vision
nocturne très vite combat lors de nos
déplacements nous avons pu constater à
quel point ce renouvellement est
apprécié dans les forces
s'agissant du respect de du programme
d'équipement les différents ajustements
annuels ont eu un impact sensible sur le
calendrier prévisionnel de même que
certains aléas c'est tout à fait naturel
tels que des retards industriels ou
encore les prélèvements effectués ça a
été évoqué dans le cadre des
exportations ou au bénéfice les forces
ukrainiennes au total
sur les 52 équipements mentionnés dans
le rapport annexé 25 n'atteindront pas
la cible du parc prévisionnel prévue au
titre du jalon 25 la plupart de ces
retards ne sont toutefois pas de nature
à remettre en cause la cible de 2030 à
titre d'exemple du nom respect du jalon
25 prévu par la LPM on peut citer le
drone tactique pétroleur ou le programme
de véhicule des forces spéciales les
victimes de problèmes industriels le
programme scorpion dans la cible a été
ramené de 50 à 45% en 2025 dans le cadre
de l'actualisation 2021 pour financer
notamment l'accélération de la
rénovation du char Leclerc et le
lancement du vbae ou encore les avions
Rafale du fait de l'exportation grecque
ou croate inversement d'autres
programmes ont été accélérés par rapport
aux prévisions les études pour le
porte-avion de nouvelle génération pour
un financier de 800 millions d'euros par
exemple enfin des programmes non prévus
initialement par la LPM ont été créés
pour tenir compte de l'évolution du
contexte stratégique maîtrise des fonds
marins ma chère collègue
comme nous l'avons vu la semaine
dernière lutte anti drone frappe longue
portée ou encore le programme cinabe
contre les menaces NRBC au final quelles
leçons tirées de cette exécution de la
LPM
gardons à l'esprit que nous n'en sommes
qu'au début du processus de
modernisation des équipements au regard
de la trajectoire qui est fixée dans
l'ambition 2030 le programme scorpion
sera à 23% d'exécution en 2023 le
passage au tour Rafale au sein de
l'armée de l'air est encore loin d'être
achevé tandis que certains grands
programmes de la marine ont commencé à
être admis au service actif où ils
seront bientôt
SNA patrouilleur outremer frégate de
défense et d'intervention bâtiment de
ravitaillement des forces par exemple il
faut donc garder le cap et surtout ne
pas réduire les volumes il faudra
également dans la prochaine lpmvi à ce
que ces nouvelles capacités soient bien
accompagnées des outils des
infrastructures requises à titre
d'exemple le premier REC bien reçu les
premiers Jaguar mais pas encore les
simulateurs les infrastructures de
maintenance sont également attendues
au-delà de cette continuité nécessaire
il faut bien sûr adapter certaines
capacités à l'évolution du contexte
stratégique notamment au retour de la
guerre à haute intensité en Europe
je ne reviendrai pas sur les munitions
la défense solaire qui vont faire
l'objet d'une présentation tout à
l'heure mais qui constitue de l'aveu
général des segments absolument clé
les formats actuels des flottes de
Rafale des frégates de premier rang
constitue des points d'attention majeurs
pour l'armée de l'air de l'espace et
pour la marine
le rehaussement de ces formats implique
évidemment des investissements très
lourds des programmes européens avec de
grosses séries par exemple celui des
corvettes européennes sont des solutions
intéressantes pour la surveillance de
nos autres de nos zones économiques
exclusives enfin
certains trous capacités doivent être
impérativement comblées sans être
exhaustif on peut citer à capacité de
frappe dans la profondeur capacité de
destruction de défense aériennes
ennemies les munitions téléopérée
la prochaine LPM devra également faire
de l'adaptation de la BITD à l'économie
de guerre un axe majeur de sa
programmation
allègement des normes
simplification des programmes d'armement
constituent des pistes à privilégier
pour être en capacité de produire plus
plus vite en cas de besoin
au regard des retards pris par certains
programmes de coopération européens la
prochaine LPM pourrait
utilement instaurer des jalons
décisionnels à intervalles réguliers
afin de décider s'il convient ou non de
poursuivre ses coopérations cela paraît
d'autant plus important que les besoins
sous-jacents à ces coopérations sont
majeures pour nos armées
que cela se fasse dans un cadre européen
ou national de toute façon il nous
faudra un successeur au Leclerc et il
nous faudra un successeur en rafale les
récentes déclarations du président de la
République et celle du chancelier
allemand vont dans le bon sens je
souhaiterais également revenir très
rapidement sur l'exécution de certaines
priories filées affichées par la LPM le
renseignement le cyber l'espace
l'innovation
s'agissant du renseignement nos services
DGSE DRM drsd sont dans une phase de
profonde transformation
transformation humaine bien sûr mais
aussi transformation capacitaire grâce à
l'effort promu dans l'actuel LPM c'est
essentiel dans un contexte d'hybridité
croissante des conflits le bon
développement du programme Artemis par
exemple programme d'intelligence
artificielle serait sera pardon une clé
pour traiter des données en croissance
exponentielle les défis en termes de
recrutement de fidélisation ont été
soulignés le renseignement constituera
du reste une priorité pour la prochaine
LPM puisque on y consacrera une hausse
de plus de 60%
pour le cyber la programmation était
marquée par des créations la création
d'une posture reflet de l'importance de
cette mission
l'essentiel des dépenses de
cyber-défense a été consacré à la crypto
le chiffre
l'augmentation des crédits consacrés
aussi bear dans le cadre de
l'actualisation de la programmation en
21 a également permis de développer la
lutte
informationnelle la lutte d'influence
qui n'était pas un axe promu
initialement les défis en matière de
ressources humaines sont cependant
majeure comme cyber n'étant qu'à 82% de
sa cible d'effectif à l'heure actuelle
s'agissant de l'espace un effort
important a été réalisé notamment pour
renouveler nos capacités satellitaires
la France est par exemple un des seuls
pays au monde disposant de capacités
spatiales de renseignement d'origine
électromagnétique
avec la constellation CRS dont la mise
en service a été accélérée à l'occasion
de du conflit ukrainien lors de la
prochaine LPM les forts devra se
concentrer sur le développement de
capacité de protection de nos satellites
mais également d'actions dans l'espace
c'est l'objet du programme Arès qui a
été lancé en 2019 quant à l'innovation
quatrième et dernière priorité de l'alpm
l'objectif d'un milliard d'euros
consacré aux études amont a été respecté
cela a permis à l'agence de l'innovation
de défense créée en 2018 de monter en
puissance un véritable écosystème a été
créé avec un foisonnement d'initiative
je pense notamment au FID le font
d'innovation de défense en 21 pour aider
les entreprises innovantes la principale
problématique aujourd'hui reste le
passage à l'action pour les innovations
avec trop de contraintes liées aux
normes
c'est des normes qui parfois sont
totalement inadaptés il est également
indispensable de ne pas rater le virage
pour certaines technologies phares le
quantique
qui vraisemblablement va demander des
efforts financiers importants mais qui
va révolutionner révolutionner les
approches dans un certain nombre de
domaines mais nos armées ne valent que
par celles et ceux qui le servent
et en associant mon collègue coraboteur
je voudrais vraiment que nous insistions
sur
l'impression générale que nous ont donné
l'ensemble des militaires et des civils
de la défense la notion du service et la
notion même du sacrifice
ultime
imprègne nos forces armées la mise en
place de la nprm je vous rappeler que
c'est quand même 500 millions d'euros en
année pleine dans cette LPM a été
particulièrement bien accueillie il
reste cependant à travailler sur la
revalorisation significative de la part
indiciaire je n'ai pas de doute sur le
fait que ce sera le cas
oui en effet je crois que mon corps
rapporteur la souligner c'est peut-être
là que se trouve le point de vigilance
le plus important de cette LPM nous en
avons identifié trois principaux en plus
de tous ceux que nous avons évoqué lors
de la présentation mais effectivement
sur le matériel et sur le financier le
rendez-vous a été honoré sur l'humain et
ce qui entoure l'humain c'est-à-dire là
où il vit comment il s'entraîne on peut
remarquer en revanche qu'on peut faire
mieux et c'est l'objet de cette dernière
partie de cette conclusion ce sont les
les points d'attention majeurs les
objectifs peu réussis ou moins réussie
de cette LPM qui doivent servir de
d'indicateurs pour la prochaine
l'activité opérationnelle donc la
fidélisation des effectifs et évidemment
les soldes qui vont avec et les
infrastructures tout d'abord sur la
préparation opérationnelle nos armées
vous le savez et nous leur rendons ici
souvent hommage et c'est un hommage
mérité sont au rendez-vous de leur
mission comme la illustré la réactivité
dans le cadre du déploiement sur le
flanc oriental à la suite de l'invasion
de la Russie en Ukraine au sujet de ces
missions la prochaine LPM devra prendre
acte du redéploiement de nos dispositifs
en Afrique et certainement renforcer
notre présence dans d'autres zones
stratégiques telles que l'Indo Pacifique
au titre des missions intérieures nous
pensons qu'il est temps
de réinterroger sentinelle de réévaluer
sentinelle et de voir comment dans
l'avenir nous pourrons éventuellement
réformer le système mais sinon armées
sont au rendez-vous de leur mission cela
se fait malheureusement
trop souvent au détriment de leur
préparation opérationnelle
les objectifs d'activité prévus par la
LPM à cet égard qui correspondent aux
normes autant il faut être clair il faut
être franc ne sont pas atteints
ce sujet ayant été abordé la semaine
dernière par nos collègues je n'y
reviendrai pas mais vous avez je crois
tous à l'esprit ce bilan mais cela
nécessite selon nous d'une part de
gagner en épaisseur notamment
d'accroître nos stocks de munitions là
aussi nous en parlerons et d'autres
parts d'améliorer encore la
disponibilité de nos équipements en
effet les objectifs de cette
disponibilité des équipements prévus par
la LPM ne sont pas atteints notamment
pour les aéronefs NH90 c130h mirage 2002
il faudra veiller dans le cadre de cette
prochaine LPM est-ce que la
verticalisation des contrats de MCO qui
a exigé un effort financier considérable
porte enfin ses fruits
l'accroissement des stocks de pièces de
rechange et la simplification des
plantes maintenant constituent dans
cette perspective des pistes que nous
devrons que nous devrons approfondir
deuxième point d'attention majeure de
mon corps-à-porteur et de moi-même ce
sont les ressources humaines
et nous insistons vraiment beaucoup sur
ce point
notamment et c'est le premier enjeu la
fidélisation
alors que la LPM prévoyait une remontée
des effectifs
6000 sur la période 2019-2025 et la
moitié en 2023 aurait dû être réalisé le
compte n'est pas du tout
atteint les schémas d'emploi
prévisionnels du ministère des armées à
la fin de l'année 2022 nous montre un
retard de plus de 1920 équivalent temps
plein par rapport à la cible
vous l'avez compris c'est un point de
vigilance extrême
or si les objectifs ne sont pas atteints
ce n'est pas tendu à des problèmes de
recrutement le ministère recrute chaque
année près de 27 000 effectifs soit près
de 10% du total des effectifs c'est
considérable
mais cela tient plutôt à un problème de
fidélisation ce déficit de fidélisation
constitue donc un point de vigilance
pour tous ceux que nous avons auditionné
je crois qu'il y a eu une quasi
unanimité et c'était spontanément le
point qui revenait en premier ou en tout
cas dans les premiers points d'attention
les causes de ce déficit sont multiples
mais nous en avidions identifié deux qui
nous sommes particulièrement importantes
d'une part le décrochage des salaires
par rapport au secteur civil
d'autre part la moindre acceptabilité
des suggestions militaires chez les
jeunes générations notamment des
mobilités géographiques dans un contexte
d'emploi accru des conjoints
très concrètement cela se traduit par le
fait que de plus en plus de militaires
durant ne souhaite pas devenir
sous-officier par exemple car le gain
salarial est trop faible par rapport au
sujets à ce nouveau statut
or le modèle de notre armée et vous le
savez repose notamment sur cette
promotion interne
sur le terrain ce déficit de
fidélisation a des conséquences très
concrètes c'est une baisse du taux
d'encadrement des plus jeunes alors même
que ses besoins d'encadrement sont
importants en raison de la hausse même
des recrutements
dans ce contexte mes chers collègues que
faire et bien tout d'abord il nous
semble impératif de faire un effort sur
le volet indiciaire comme le disait mon
corps rapporteur de la rémunération des
militaires dans le cadre de la prochaine
LPM la refonte du volet indemnitaire par
la nprm est-elle la bienvenue et a été
saluée par nos militaires mais nous
sommes aujourd'hui arrivés au bout de
cette logique on ne pourra pas lutter
contre 100 sentiment de décrochage de
nos militaires sans une revalorisation
significative de la paradisiaque
deuxièmement
la fidélisation nécessite de recruter le
plus tôt possible car plus les
militaires entre tôt dans l'institution
plus ils sont fidèles à celle-ci les
initiatives innovantes telles que
l'école militaire est préparatoire et
technique de Bourges ou encore le BTS
cyber de Saint-Cyr-l'École doivent être
amplifiés notamment pour recruter dans
les secteurs en tension
enfin la fidélisation passe également
par l'attention portée aux conditions de
vie des militaires et de leur famille à
cet égard le plan famille a été
globalement bien accueilli par les
militaires et l'annonce par le ministère
des armées d'un plan famille 2 doté de
750 millions d'euros dans le cadre de la
prochaine LPM et certainement positif
j'en viens mes chers collègues pour
terminer cette présentation à notre
troisième point d'attention majeur les
infrastructures
sujet qui est lié du reste à ce qu'on
vient d'évoquer sur la condition
militaire parce que l'état des
infrastructures joue évidemment sur le
moral des troupes et donc sur la
fidélisation des effectifs comme vous le
savez les infarctus structures ont été
le parent pauvre des précédentes
programmation avec des décennies
sous-investissement c'est assez
matérialisé par une forte dégradation du
parc existant aujourd'hui seul un quart
un quart du parc immobilier du ministère
est considéré être dans un bon état ou
neuf
vous avez compris en creux trois quarts
mérite notre attention ce que l'on
appelle la dette grise c'est à dire
l'ensemble des dépenses nécessaires pour
uniquement remettre en état le parc
existant à être un nouveau record de 4,5
milliards d'euros
un effort de modernisation important à
certes et été réalisée dans le cadre de
la LPM notamment pour les bergement de
nos militaires de rang durant pardon
avec le doublement de l'enveloppe
budgétaire par rapport à la précédente
LPM l'entretien des logements domaniaux
connaîtra également une nouvelle
dynamique avec le contrat de concession
ambition logement conclu pour une durée
de 35 ans et pour un engagement total de
2,8 milliards d'euros
les infrastructures opérationnelles sont
également modernisées pour accueillir
les nouvelles capacités
issues de la LPM
mais soyons honnêtes nous avons constaté
lors de nos déplacements que les besoins
sont encore immenses
vétusté des hébergements qui seraient
considérés comme indigne dans le civil
inadaptation des hangars de stockage et
de maintenance son nouveau équipement
nous avons même vu dans une des unités
que nous avons visités que l'on se
chauffait encore au charbon
nous avons vu des réseaux d'eau et
d'électricité vieillissant qui ne
permettait plus en fonctionnement normal
il est par conséquent impératif que la
prochaine LPM amplifie les
investissements pour réduire cette dette
grise il en va des conditions de vie des
conditions d'exercice de leur mission et
donc du moral de nos soldats
au-delà de l'effort financier il faut
également revoir les processus
décisionnels en donnant davantage de
pouvoir au chef de corps qui seul
connaît les véritables besoins de son
unité combien de chefs de corps nous ont
expliqué que pour remplacer la moindre
tuyauterie ou la moindre le moindre
chauffage de douche il fallait remplir
des tonnes de paperasse que des
fonctionnaires se renvoyaient les uns
aux autres pour savoir qui investiraient
et des mois voire des années après rien
n'était fait une enveloppe
discrétionnaire pourrait par exemple
être alloué à ces chefs de corps pour
être en capacité de traiter rapidement
les menus réparations il n'est pas
normal que mené aux militaire doivent
attendre plusieurs mois la réparation
d'une fenêtre cassée nous l'avons vu ou
d'un toit qui fuit alors que leur
régiment ou leur base accueille des
équipements à la pointe de la
technologie
l'écart entre le matériel qui arrive et
les conditions de vie qui date d'il y a
40 ans de certains n'est plus accepté et
je dirais même n'est plus acceptable
le rôle du service d'infrastructure de
la défense le fameux Sid pourrait
également être revu en se recentrant
davantage sur les infrastructures
technicoopérationnelles c'est son cœur
de métier et en externalisant les
travaux de nature davantage civil bien
sûr avec un droit de regard bien sûr
avec de la vigilance ça paraît évident
enfin et c'est un peu redondant avec ce
que ce que tu as dit mais les normes
souvent issues du monde civil sont
parfois inadaptés au secteur militaire
et elle gagnerait être simplifiée afin
de réduire les coûts et les délais des
travaux à titre d'exemple sur la base
aérienne d'Orléans Brissy les aviateurs
ont dû attendre près de 18 mois pour
utiliser un hangar pourtant livré faute
d'avoir les autorisations
environnementales nécessaires
au final mes chers collègues comme vous
l'avez compris le bilan est globalement
positif mais il reste de très nombreux
défis à relever nous n'en sommes qu'au
début de la trajectoire de redressement
de nos armées de la prochaine LPM et ce
sera essentiel d'être vigilant pour
amplifier la dynamique
bien sûr il s'agit de passer d'une
logique de réparation ce que tu
expliquais en introduction de cette LPM
à une logique de modernisation de nos
armées
mais la réparation n'est pas terminée
réparation et modernisation devront être
menées de concert si nous voulons
réussir
la prochaine LPM qui va nous occuper
dans les semaines et les mois qui
viennent aura certainement beaucoup de
défis à relever mais la précédente LPM
aura construit un socle solide sur
lequel on pourra s'appuyer nous aura
montré aussi ce qui marchait et ce qui
ne fonctionnait pas 413 milliards
c'est le budget annoncé par Monsieur le
Président de la République 413 milliards
ça se gère
ça se prévoit ça s'organise ça se suit
ça se corrige et donc il faudra que les
indicateurs soient mis en place que le
Parlement soit pleinement pleinement
concertés et associés aux décisions et
il faudra que cette 403 milliards
servent bien sûr à ce qui est valorisant
ce qui est plaisant à montrer dans les
médias c'est-à-dire le technologie mais
qui n'oublie jamais jamais
ceux qui fait la force de nos armées les
femmes et les hommes qui la composent
merci beaucoup merci à tous les deux
pour cette importante au travail je
pense que vous avez mis la bonne hauteur
et que vous êtes vous avez également eu
le sens du détail vous avez à la fois
abordé les sujets de fond sur
l'affectation des ressources mais
également aborder le sujet de méthode
que ce soit le périmètre du financement
intermédiaire la prise en compte de
l'inflation les coopérations européennes
les modes d'actualisation etc et
j'espère que c'est important en travail
nous permettra d'être mieux armé pour
l'étude de la prochaine LPM alors nous
avons un peu moins d'une heure pour
l'ensemble des questions et nous allons
commencer par les orateurs de groupe
pour le groupe Renaissance la parole est
à Jean-Michel Jacques merci monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues je tiens
tout d'abord au nom du groupe
Renaissance à souligner la qualité du
travail accompli par nos deux
corps-à-porteurs et leur équipe qui en
fait un travail remarquable
vous nous rappelez à travers votre votre
travail le rôle du député du
parlementaire qui est celui de voter la
loi et on peut se réjouir du travail
trans partisan qui a été fait lors de la
dernière loi de programmation militaire
auquel j'ai eu l'honneur avec un certain
nombre collègues de participer et puis
ce rôle aussi d'évaluation que vous
venez de faire avec précision et dont on
peut se réjouir tout de même parce que
bien que vous nous avez rapporté un
certain point d'attention qu'il va
falloir absolument prendre en compte
pour la nouvelle loi de programmation et
vient nous pouvons aussi constater une
évolution tout de même positive pour
nous armées depuis un certain nombre
d'années alors la dernière loi de
programmation militaire
2019-2025 répond aux enjeux sécuritaires
identifiés par la revue stratégique
élaboré en 2017 et à ce moment-là le
contexte se caractérisé entre autres par
une menace terroriste importante et
particulièrement élevée par une crise
majeure au sel mais aussi par une forte
déstabilisation aux proches et
Moyen-Orient
ces enjeux n'ont pas disparu comme vous
avez pu nous le souligner mais ont
évolué
à ceci ce sont ajoutés de nouvelles
menaces comme le retour de la guerre en
Europe la multiplication des menaces
hybrides ou encore
l'appétence grandissante de certains
états pour les espaces communs et je
pense aux espaces matériels comme
l'espace
extra atmosphérique que vous avez
évoquée l'espace tout simplement émet
aussi
sous-marin ainsi que l'espace immatériel
le numérique entre autres le cyber mais
aussi l'espace informationnel
alors ces évolutions nous obligent à
transformer notre outil militaire il
nous faudra donc veiller collectivement
à ce que soit bien pris en compte dans
la prochaine loi de programmation
militaire tous ces faits
cette nouvelle situation géostratégique
nous oblige à entrer dans une logique
d'économie de guerre et vous nous l'avez
bien souligné
en la matière quelles doivent être selon
vous nos axes d'amélioration pour y
parvenir
par ailleurs sur un tout autre volet
mais tout aussi importants qui sont les
ressources humaines vous ne l'avez bien
souligné par une phrase qui m'a réjouit
les armées ne valent que par ceux qui le
servent et c'est vrai que on le voit
bien dans la guerre en Ukraine c'est
toujours à la fin de la fin c'est le
soldat qui soit un homme ou une femme
qui porte le fusil qui fera la
différence et comme vous vous le savez
nous avons
nous devons continuer à renforcer
l'attractivité la fidélisation de nos
armées avec la dernière loi de
programmation militaire beaucoup a déjà
été fait je pense par exemple à la mise
en place de la prime du lien de service
toutefois nous avons bien entendu que
vous proposez de compléter la mise en
place de notre nouvelle politique de
rémunération du militaire nprm par un
effort sur le volet indiciaire
pourriez-vous nous repréciser par quoi
cette proposition est-elle motivée je
vous remercie merci pour le groupe
rassemblement national la parole est à
Caroline Colombier
oui monsieur le Président Monsieur les
rapporteurs chers collègues au nom du
groupe rassemblant national nous
souhaitons tout d'abord vous remercier
pour le travail effectué autour de cette
mission d'information et nous attendons
avec un grand impatience de pouvoir lire
votre votre rapport et nous en
remercions les éléments que vous
apportez nous vous apportez nous donne
une base solide pour élaborer
efficacement la prochaine loi la
prochaine LPM dans un contexte
géostratégique en perpétuel évolution
pour ne pas dire en constante ébullition
nous nous félicitons bien évidemment du
respect global de la précédente LPM qui
constitue un motif d'encouragement pour
nos armées après ces années de disette
budgétaires mais l'effort est encore à
poursuivre car votre rapport confirme
les constats effectués par notre groupe
depuis quelques temps à savoir entre
autres la persistante la persistance de
nombreux manques pour nos armées et
l'urgence d'une remontée en puissance
assumée de notre outil de défense pour
être à la hauteur des enjeux de demain à
ce sujet n'oublions pas que la
réparation entamée par la LPM devait
s'étendre initialement jusqu'à 2025 et
callobe d'entamer la prochaine cette
réparation n'est toujours pas aboutie
telle que vous venez de nous l'indiquer
les points d'inquiétude demeurent donc
nombreux tout d'abord la dualité
persistante entre une volonté
d'indépendance et de souveraineté pour
garantir notre liberté d'action dans de
nombreux secteurs comme catapulte ou
petit calibre drone hélicoptère lourdes
de transport et encore d'autres d'autres
points et la poursuite d'illusoires
projets avec des partenaires qui ne
partagent pas la même vision stratégique
et industrielle le second point
d'inquiétude est que les gouvernements
précédents ont réduit nos armées à un
modèle expéditionnaire adapté au temps
de paix relatives mais un propre à la
haute intensité que provoque le retour
des logiques de puissance donc nous
avons parlé diverses reprises ces
derniers temps aussi la France a adopté
un format capacitaire fondé sur du
matériel
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président
messieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues je vous remercie pour votre
travail très intéressant transpartisan
et vraiment hautement important pour
notre commission je regrette simplement
permettez-moi de vous le dire que vous
nous l'ayez pas transmis avant la
commission parce que c'est quand même
une mine de renseignements et on aurait
pu travailler un peu mieux dirais-je
voilà je le regrette et je voulais vous
le dire je souhaite vous interroger sur
l'impact de la guerre en Ukraine sur la
LPM cette guerre a mobilisé mobilise
toujours énormément d'effectifs aux
frontières et énormément de matériel en
provenance de la France pour renforcer
l'armée ukrainienne et j'aimerais savoir
si durant vos auditions les militaires
que vous avez avec lesquels vous avez
échangé ce sont plein de de cette de ces
envois de matériel et d'hommes aux
frontières et surtout quel a été
l'impact est-ce que vous avez pu le
mesurer dans la LPM 19 25 je vous
remercie merci pour le groupe démocrate
la parole est à Christophe Blanchet
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
rapporteurs chers collègues le groupe
démocrate vous remercie pour vos
excellentes travaux très éclairant sur
le bilan de cette loi de programmation
militaire 2019-2025
prouvant aussi que nos engagements du
programme présidentiel en 2017 ont été
tenus ne serait-ce que de points de vue
financier et matériel tel qu'il était
décrit dans le programme du président
Emmanuel Macron même si on doit faire
mieux pour réparer 40 ans d'oubli et
d'hémorragie comme vous l'avez souligné
un début de cette loi était de permettre
à la France d'affirmer son autonomie
stratégique c'est-à-dire d'être un
partenaire fiable et crédible capable de
décider d'agir sans dépendre des
capacités d'autres États
l'objectif sous-jacent était de
construire les conditions d'une
autonomie stratégique européenne par la
coopération industrielle et
opérationnelle afin de construire une
culture stratégique commune comme vous
l'avez montré lors de ces quatre années
les armées françaises ont pu renouveler
leurs équipements et acquérir de
nouvelles capacités notamment pour se
défendre dans les nouveaux champs de
conflictualité
des équipements du quotidien essentiel
au soldats ont été livrés des chantiers
de rénovation et de construction de
logements et d'infrastructure
opérationnels ont été lancées pourtant
l'objectif de régénération des armées
n'a pas été totalement atteint leur
apport de la Cour des comptes de mai
2022 souligne notamment que la très
forte sollicitation opérationnelle a
entraîné des conséquences sur
l'entraînement des forces et la
disponibilité des matériels et que les
armées françaises ne sont pas prêtes ni
en termes d'équipement ni en terme de
préparation en cas d'opération majeure
de haute intensité concernant la
coopération européenne des projets comme
celui de l'eurodrome ou le missile
franco-italien de défense solaire Aster
témoignent d'une volonté de redire les
coûts de production et de favoriser une
interopéabilité des armées européennes
mais lisez il est aussi important de
rappeler que de nombreux États européens
en particulier sur le flanc Est de
l'Europe compte encore sur la protection
du parapluie nucléaire américain et
encore plus depuis la guerre en Ukraine
ils achètent des blindés des missiles
des pièces d'artillerie et surtout des
avions de chasse F35 aux États-Unis
la situation actuelle en Europe nous
pousse aujourd'hui plus que jamais à
vouloir accentuer l'autonomie
stratégique de notre pays et de notre
continent dans un contexte qui n'est
plus le même qui a 4 ans la prochaine
LPM que nous serons amenés à étudier
sans prendre en compte la nécessité
d'accentuer plus encore nos efforts sur
cette question d'autonomie continentale
mais il s'agit de savoir en tirer les
leçons des dernières années la France et
l'Allemagne peine à se mettre d'accord
sur le Scaff et le mgcs le Sénat a même
été un amendement visant à anticiper une
impasse des négociations pour le SCAF et
incitant à envisager la faisabilité d'un
projet de chasseurs de nouvelles
génération uniquement français la France
a également décidé de ne pas participer
au projet de provoquer antimicile
européen j'aurais donc trois questions
quel serait les outils de diplomatie
militaire pour convaincre nos alliés
européens de construire ensemble une
autonomie stratégique européenne afin de
ne plus dépendre des États-Unis et de ne
pas faire supporter seul les coûts des
OPEX en intervie ministériel
sur la question de la fidélisation vous
êtes vous penché sur le RO2 et la garde
républicaine qui peut participer
évidemment à la fidélisation de nos
armées dans un meilleur travail et enfin
vous avez évoqué en vos propos
introductif que la LPM notre armée c'est
le pacte entre la nation et son armée
aujourd'hui on va très bien que le pacte
entre la représentation nationale et son
armée et là et est effectué mais pour
autant est-ce que la nation a vraiment
conscience qu'elle est dans le pacte
avec son armée
merci chers collègues j'ai cru entendre
garder républicaine vous vouliez parler
de garde nationale oui il me semble
merci chers collègues pour le groupe
socialiste la parole est à anapick
merci monsieur le Président messieurs
les rapporteurs à l'occasion de la
présentation de la future LPM le
président de la République se féliciter
de présenter un nouveau projet faisant
suite à la parfaite exécution de la loi
précédente votre rapport nuance
utilement les choses et soulève quelques
points sur lesquels nous souhaiterions
avoir un autre tour quelques précisions
cette première partie de la LPM avait la
vocation de réparer nos armées et de les
sortir de la logique de pénurie force
est de constater que la réalisation de
ces objectifs n'est pas complètement
atteinte malgré des avancées et que les
objectifs budgétaires combinés au
contexte inflationniste pourrait
grandement en ralentir la pleine
réalisation
en effet comme l'indique la Cour des
comptes dans son rapport sur la LPM de
2019-2025 l'ambition d'un modèle d'armée
complet et équilibré d'ici 2030 est
difficile à concilier avec la réduction
du déficit public à 3% du PIB en 2027
formuler en 2017 cette ambition n'a pas
fait l'objet d'une actualisation depuis
au cours de votre rapport comment vous
interlocuteurs ont-ils évoqué cette
absence d'actualisation ont-ils par
ailleurs mis en avant le souhait qu'un
beau livre blanc soit réalisé par
ailleurs si l'on se focalise un peu sur
la seule logique de pénurie nos travaux
sur la préparation opérationnelle
souligne le manque de disponibilité de
matériel du matériel au sein de nos
armées et vous l'avez à votre tour
souligné le manque de munitions
régulièrement évoqué tout comme
l'indisponibilité des matériels et
notamment notamment des avions et
aéronefs ou d'espaces d'entraînement
comme les champs de tir si l'on rajoute
à ces observations la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre qui touche le secteur
industriel dans quelle mesure selon vous
cette faille dans la disponibilité
matérielle aurait pu être évité au
regard du bilan que vous faites de la
précédente LPM au cours de vos auditions
avez-vous eu des retours sur
d'éventuelles alertes lancées à propos
de cette disponibilité matérielle enfin
la précédente LPM initié la volonté de
renforcer le lien armé nation et
favoriser notamment un solide esprit de
défense faisant suite aux attentats de
2015 et plus encore avec la crise
sanitaire la résilience a marqué la
volonté du pouvoir de conditionner de
préparer la nation au conflit au-delà de
mon avis personnel qui persiste à penser
que le terme même de conditionnement et
potentiellement dangereux nous aimerions
savoir dans quelle mesure au cours de
vos travaux diriez-vous que l'objectif
d'établir ou de rétablir le lien armée
nation fut remplie par nos armées durant
cette première partie de la LPM si la
Cour des comptes invite à reconsidérer
la mission sentinelle ce point fut-il
évoqué par vos interlocuteurs au cours
des auditions merci merci vous avez de
la chance chers collègues le chronomètre
n'était pas lancé donc j'ai pas de souci
vous avez dépassé ou pas les autres ont
largement
[Rires]
et enfin pour le groupe horizon la
parole est à anneau merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur
[Musique]
vraiment passionnant merci beaucoup
quelle équation difficile nous avons à
résoudre tous ensemble sur la loi de
programmation militaire à venir je
m'intéresserai plus particulièrement un
des aspects
notamment celui de l'innovation et la
prospective technologique
ici même en audition le chef
d'état-major de l'armée de l'air et
l'espace indiquaient que la France avait
pris du retard sur un certain nombre de
sujets au niveau technologique qui ne
seraient pas rattrapable mais par contre
qu'on avait une ambition d'être leader
sur certains au niveau européen
j'entends sur certains sujets notamment
en lien avec l'espace
de la même manière au niveau du comme
cimer qu'on a eu le plaisir de visiter
dans le cadre du GT espace et cyber à la
question directe que je posais aux
militaires qui étaient là estimez-vous
que l'investissement est nécessaire pour
que vous puissiez bien faire votre
travail au niveau du comme cyber
l'obligation de réserve des militaires
ne leur a pas permis de me répondre et
c'est tout à fait normal mais il
n'empêche que je conserve cette question
dans dans ma tête et aussi la question
portera sur ces investissements du futur
et l'innovation notamment l'espace et le
cyber en particulier
estimez-vous que les choix effectués
lors de la LPM
2019-2025 auront permis de positionner
la France sur une bonne tendance c'est à
dire en pôle position sur ces
thématiques au niveau européen voire
mondiale et notamment en capacité à
répondre aux enjeux et ambition de notre
pays sur ces sujets je vous remercie
merci je vous rappelle que l'audition
doit être terminé à 10h40 il nous reste
cinq questions je vous propose de les
prendre maintenant pour que les rapports
et chacun une quinzaine de minutes pour
pour répondre à l'ensemble de ces
questions la parole est à Stéphanie
guelzi
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
rapporteurs je vous remercie pour la
présentation de ces éléments sur le
bilan de la LPM 2019-2025 ainsi que pour
votre travail exhaustif dans le cadre de
cette mission d'information nos
militaires s'engagent de la plus noble
des manières pour la défense de la
France et des Français nous devons en
retour leur permettre de mettre en œuvre
cet engagement dans les meilleures
conditions possibles tout le monde ici
pour en convenir cela passe entre autres
par de bonnes conditions d'hébergement
et une meilleure qualité des
infrastructures dans lesquelles ils sont
amenés à évoluer
vous nous démontrez que les efforts
budgétaires ont été consentis en faveur
des infrastructures toutefois comme vous
l'avez expliqué des décennies de
sous-investissement imputables
gouvernement successifs de droites comme
de gauche en profondément fragilisées
nos infrastructures vous révélez la
nécessité d'adapter de nombreuses
infrastructures en vue d'accueillir de
nouveaux équipements mais également de
besoin impérieux de procéder à nombreux
travaux de rénovation je ne peux que
souscrire à ce constat dans ma
circonscription lors d'une visite de la
gendarmerie de Murviel-les-Béziers j'ai
pu constater le délabrement des
bâtiments dont une partie menace
carrément de s'écrouler véritable
passoire thermique les gendarmes et
leurs familles ont été contraints de
fuir vers le locatif privé afin d'éviter
les conditions de vie indigne dans ces
bâtiments malgré les efforts mis en
oeuvre par le maire de la commune
même l'accueil de cette gendarmerie
n'est pas adaptée à l'accueil du public
puisqu'elle ne dispose pas d'accès ERP
et là encore une fois une véritable
passoire thermique cette situation
s'explique en partie par le recours à
une entreprise privée pour le pilotage
des opérations de construction mais
également pour leur gestion et entretien
plus gros plus globallement lors de vos
travaux vous avez eu l'occasion de vous
déplacer sur des bases et de constater
l'état des locaux estimez-vous que leur
état est à la hauteur de l'engagement de
ces femmes et de ces hommes qui
défendent notre nation le cas échéant
estimez-vous que l'externalisation de la
construction et de l'entretien des
infrastructures de vie basiques soit une
solution envisageable pour répondre à
leurs besoins je vous remercie merci la
parole est à Lionel Royer Perrot
merci monsieur le Président donc à mon
tour de féliciter les rapporteurs pour
l'excellence de leur rapport et de nous
avoir une nouvelle fois permis de
réaffirmer le fait que cette historique
dans l'histoire de nos armées que cette
loi de programmation militaire était
totalement exécuté pour celui qui a
œuvré pendant quasiment 20 ans dans ses
locaux et bien je peux dire
qu'effectivement c'est
quasiment exceptionnel pour ne pas dire
exceptionnel tout court que nous ayons
une loi de programmation militaire qui
soit totalement réalisée la question
portera plus précisément sur la
difficulté de recrutement et de
fidélisation de nos jeunes vous l'avez
évoqué tout à l'heure effectivement
cette absence de fidélisation s'est
traduit par la dénonciation des contrats
en cours de période probatoire notamment
mais également par l'absence de
renouvellement des contrats arrivés à
terme à titre d'exemple notre collègue
François Cormier bouligeon dans son
rapport pour avis du budget 2023 de
l'armée de terre indiquait que pour les
militaires du rang le taux de
dénonciation des contrats des militaires
durant atteignaient près de 32% alors
que le taux de renouvellement des
contrats pour cette catégorie n'est que
de
37,5%. donc ce phénomène global me
semble-t-il doit nous préoccuper car il
explique quand même le non respect des
schémas d'emploi prévu dans le cadre de
la LPM et que disposer des compétences
idoine et en nombre suffisant est une
nécessité qui va de pair avec les
efforts capacitaires donc vous avez
tracé un certain nombre de pistes de
réflexion et je voudrais savoir quel
serait la hiérarchie ou la
hiérarchisation des priorités quelque
part qu'est-ce que vous pourriez
suggérer dans nos travaux pour cibler
les premières décisions nécessaires à
prendre en ce domaine je vous en
remercie merci la parole est à Frédéric
bocaletti
ce président merci aux rapporteur
Yannick chenvers et Laurent Jacoby pour
leur travail chers collègue
alors que les livraisons de nouveaux
équipements tels que les drones
Patroller et autres hélicoptères de
combat battent leur plainte le taux de
disponibilité des matériels existants de
me retrouver faibles il est
malheureusement de notoriété publique
que les armées sont dans l'obligation de
canaval cannibalisé par non ce qui
signifie désosser des matériels pour y
prélever des pièces afin d'assurer le
maintien en conditions opérationnelles
d'autres équipements le conflit
ukrainien met également le conflit entre
l'Azerbaïdjan et l'Arménie nous démontre
aussi qu'un conflit moderne entre deux
puissances à capacité équivalente
entraîne un taux de perte humaine et
matériel accru si la mondialisation la
modernisation des équipements des armées
est un sujet à ne pas négliger celui de
faire gagner en capacité nos armées et
tout autant dès lors suite à votre
travail riche et fou si vous pertinent
qu'en parallèle de la livraison de
nouveaux matériels un effort
supplémentaire en termes de rénovation
des matériels soient menées je vous
remercie merci pour la parole est à
jamais Jean-Marie Fiévet
merci monsieur le Président merci
Monsieur aventure pour votre travail
très fourni comme cela a été rappelé
dans le respect de la programmation
financière de cette LPM constitue une
nette rupture avec LPM précédente
il a permis une augmentation totale du
budget de la mission défense de l'ordre
de 28,4%
passez ainsi de 34,2 milliards d'euros
en 2018 à 43,9 milliards d'euros en 823
soit 9,7 milliards d'euros
d'augmentation
une augmentation bien supérieure à
l'augmentation générale du budget de la
même période
vous avez abordé dans votre présentation
l'exécution du programme d'équipement
prévu par la LPM ainsi que les grands
programmes bénéficiaires de cette
augmentation des crédits de la mission
défense je me réjouis que cette hausse
des crédits permise par LPM en cours
permettent de réparer et redresser nos
armées et bien ainsi traduire notre
ambition stratégique de disposer d'un
modèle d'armée complet et équilibré pour
agir sur l'ensemble du spectre à
l'horizon 2030
cela sera rendu possible grâce à la
modernisation de nos capacités
au-delà de la traduction de cette hausse
en nouvelle capacité disponible
disposez-vous d'informations relatives à
l'impact de ces investissements sur
notre BITD et plus largement sur
l'économie pour notre pays je vous
remercie merci enfin la parole est à
Christian Gérard
oui c'est mieux avec le micro merci
je reprends donc merci monsieur le
Président merci messieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues merci pour
les précieux éléments que vous apportez
au cours de cette audition en effet tout
est bien clair nous sommes tous
convaincus que les guerres d'aujourd'hui
et de demain se gagneront grâce à la
performance des équipements dont les
armées se dot cependant les matériels
c'est bien mais les hommes c'est mieux
les armées sont en effet confrontées un
véritable problème de ressources
humaines avec des carences
d'attractivité et de fidélisation des
effectifs à l'heure même où nos forces
doivent gagner en masse et en épaisseur
même si beaucoup de choses ont déjà été
faites comme la nouvelle politique de
rémunération et le plan de famille
globalement salué par nos militaires les
problèmes demeurent aussi quelle
solution vous semble possible pour
accroître l'attractivité et la
fidélisation de nos soldats marins et
aviateur je vous remercie merci enfin la
parole est à
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
kora porteur tout d'abord merci pour
votre excellent travail un joli tandem
un beau duo
les partisans d'une Europe de la défense
sont des coopérations industrielles une
vitrine des grands programmes
structurants comme en témoigne des
exemples du Skaf le système de combat
aérien du futur et du MGS le système
principal de combat terrestre force et
de constater que ces deux projets comme
tant d'autres rencontres des difficultés
il y a des désaccords industriels et ou
politiques notamment avec l'Allemagne à
titre d'exemple le programme
franco-allemand Moses l'avion
patrouilleur maritime n'a pas vu le jour
car nous savons que les Allemands
contractés avec les États-Unis pour
l'achat d'avion dès lors au regard du
bilan mitigé et se dire cela est un
euphémisme de ces multiples coopérations
européennes il semble que des
enseignements doivent être tirés de ces
difficultés pour l'avenir certes les
intérêts français allemand en matière de
défense se recoupent par endroits mais
il convient de reconnaître qu'il
divergent grandement par ailleurs là où
l'Allemagne privilégie permet
continental adapté pour des combats en
Europe on le voit de encore aujourd'hui
la France aspire à défendre ses intérêts
et ceux de ses alliés à travers le monde
la capacité de projection est une
spécificité majeure de nos armées qui en
Europe ne se retrouve qu'au Royaume-Uni
bien sûr il faut ajouter à cela notre
dimension de puissance du clair et ce
que cela implique sur le volet
capacitaire dès lors j'aurai une
question vous évoquez la nécessité de
prévoir de toute façon des remplaçants
au Leclerc et rafales qu'ils soient
européen ou nationaux un plan B sur des
programmes d'une telle ampleur nécessite
que nous industriels s'y préparent bien
en amont si nous ne voulons pas prendre
un retard dramatique polo force à la
lumière de votre travaux estimez-vous
nécessaire de missionner dès à présent
nos industriels merci merci alors il
nous reste une trentaine de minutes et
donc je propose de rapporteurs de
répondre chacun en une quinzaine de
minutes merci monsieur le président
il y a un certain nombre de questions
merci d'abord pour pour la qualité de
vos questions mes chers collègues une
première question qui touche en fait la
notion d'économie de guerre l'impact des
normes et
évidemment il y avait en creux aussi une
question sur la rémunération de des
personnels oui l'impact budgétaire de la
norme il est assez terrifiant
on a même du mal imaginé par exemple
qu'on impose dans des bâtiments qui
n'accueillent que des commandos d'avoir
des salles de bain qui sont aux normes
PMR ça a un coût et un moment donné on
se dit à quoi ça sert dès l'instant où
on a on a des personnels qui sont pas en
situation d'être opérationnelle ils sont
plus dans ces bâtiments donc c'est le
premier élément il y en a un autre qui
j'allais dire à un coût encore plus
élevé c'est la norme riche donc cette
norme c'est une norme européenne
notamment sur sur les histoires de
substances de restriction de substances
chimiques cette norme là en fait elle a
eu un impact pour la marine sur ces
fabrications d'asters et d'exocètes de
480 millions d'euros sur son propre
budget et même mes chers collègues vous
savez ce qu'on fait avec 480 millions
d'euros
je vais vous le dire
on fait c'est pour ça que je vous pose
la question
on fait je parle de pour la marine
naturellement puisque ça a été pris sur
le budget de la marine on fait plus de
10 patrouilleurs d'outre-mer plus de 10
patrouilleurs d'outre-mer c'est un peu
plus de 37 millions d'euros le
patrouiller d'outre-mer et pour la
surveillance de notre zone économique
exclusive vous savez qu'aujourd'hui on
en assise qui font commander il y en a
un qui est en transit pour rejoindre la
Nouvelle-Calédonie mais donc on en fait
10 pour la norme on fait également si on
le souhaite un bâtiment de
ravitaillement des forces bâtiment de
ravitaillement des forces c'est 425
millions d'euros on a absolument besoin
de 4 bâtiments de ravitaillement des
forces pour assurer la cohésion du
fonctionnement de notre marine donc
voilà l'impact de la norme pour les
rémunérations mais je pense qu'on y
reviendra également tous les deux parce
qu'on est vraiment pour le coup
totalement en harmonie sur le sujet ce
que nous avons entendu notamment à
l'audition des membres du Conseil
supérieur à fonction militaire
oui les militaires sont satisfaits de la
nprm oui très clairement il le disent
500 millions d'euros d'efforts dans la
LPM en année pleine c'est évidemment du
jamais vu et en même temps on peut
rappeler que cette nprm c'est le
regroupement de 174 prime pour remettre
tout ça dans 8 réparties en trois volets
je vous laisse imaginer
heureusement qu'on l'a pas confié ça à
ceux qui s'étaient occupés de du
logiciel Louvois pour la solde militaire
donc là une PRN ça marche mais c'est pas
tout
il y a évidemment les conditions de vie
nos militaires on en a parlé on pourra y
revenir si vous voulez mais il y a aussi
la notion de reprise de la grille
indiciaire c'est revenu en boucle
systématiquement c'est très net parce
qu'à un moment donné nos militaires ont
sentiments de complètement décrocher par
rapport au monde civil par rapport aux
entreprises aux salariés du civil mais
également par rapport à la fonction
publique donc se décrochage en fait il
est aussi à l'origine du départ
mon collègue jacobelli disait tout à
l'heure on a une cible de recrutement à
6000 personnes sur l'ensemble de de la
loi de programmation militaire mais pour
arriver à 6000 quand vous avez le volume
des entrées des sorties aujourd'hui on
sait que pour l'instant la cible on
l'atteint pas donc il faut réussir à
garder nos militaires il y avait
également une question
il y a eu d'abord une affirmation
de notre collègue pique
relative à la Cour des comptes
c'est tout à fait intéressant d'ailleurs
d'entendre la Cour des comptes s'occuper
de l'affaire militaires parce que comme
tout le monde le sait ils sont
extrêmement efficaces sur le terrain en
opération moi il y a un moment donné où
je m'interroge il faut toujours rappeler
ce qu'est le budget de la défense et à
quoi il sert donc très bien la Cour des
comptes fait son travail mais à un
moment donné quand on veut une nation
indépendante puissante qui pèse sur les
affaires du monde qui est membre
permanent du Conseil de sécurité de
l'ONU il y a un moment où il faut
arrêter de faire des petits comptes
d'apothicaire il faut mettre le paquet
et pour le coup cette toile de
programmation militaire elle a mis le
paquet et la suivante va la doubler si
on sera à 413 millions d'euros donc
attention moi je suis évidemment
j'allais dire
[Musique]
donc il y a évidemment pour la
fidélisation les conditions de vie
notamment pour les hommes durant Laurent
jacobelli a d'ailleurs rappelé que
aujourd'hui vous avez des capots au chef
qui ne veulent pas passer sergent
pourquoi parce que quelque part le
différentiel financier est tellement
léger qu'à côté du différentiel
financier ils vont se retrouver avec des
responsabilités et des contraintes
professionnelles dont il considère que
ça vaut pas le coup sauf que
nos armées sont le plus beau des
escaliers sociaux social pardon 50% de
nos hommes durant
deviennent sous-officiers 50% de nous
sous-officiers deviennent officiers
enfin je crois pas qui est dans la
société civile un univers dans lequel on
permet aux gens qui bossent ce qu'il
faut travailler faut pas évidemment
attendre que le Saint-Esprit vous touche
pour avoir de l'avancement faut
travailler mais que les gens qui
travaillent puissent s'élever et prendre
des responsabilités donc oui il y a cela
il y a évidemment un moment donné tout
ce qui relève de la des mouvements des
mutations on a parfois entendu de
militaires qui nous disaient ben ok nous
on sait qu'on a déménagé mais à un
moment donné le coût des déménagements
ont explosé mais la prime de
déménagement elle-même elle suit pas il
y a plein d'éléments comme ça qui font
qu'à un moment donné on se retrouve sur
l'importance de la grille indiciaire
parce que qui dit grille indiciaire dit
à l'arrivée montant de la pension
un autre élément en question c'est
Jean-Marie Fiévet sur la bit
bon là aussi l'impact de la LPM sur la
BITD il est gigantesque et l'effet
levier de l'injection de de crédit sur
notre base industrielle technologique de
défense il est incroyable je vais vous
donner juste un exemple un milliard
d'euros investi ça a un effet levier sur
10 ans de 2 milliards 2 milliards et
donc aujourd'hui on a 4000 entreprises
en France sur la BITD on a 200 000
emplois et depuis 2017 en fait
l'injection de crédit dans la LPM a créé
30000 emplois 30 000 emplois
oui c'est vrai 30000 emplois donc voilà
on voit de manière très très claire
l'importance du fait que on a évidemment
une mission c'est de donner à nos forces
armées la capacité d'assurer la défense
de ce que nous sommes de nos valeurs car
si vous défendez pas
vos valeurs y compris par les armes
regardez ce qui se passe en Ukraine à un
moment donné vous disparaissez et tout
le reste disparaît là capacité à faire
connaître son mécontentement la capacité
à s'exprimer tout ça disparaît donc en
réalité les crédits qui sont affectés à
la défense ils sont supra de tout le
reste tout le reste donc c'est important
de le rappeler et puis peut-être un
dernier élément
on a évoqué l'espace et le renseignement
je pense que vraiment en matière de
renseignement on a fait un saut on a
fait un saut en avant qui était norme
d'abord la LPM c'était 1500
personnels supplémentaires recrutés
entre la DRM la drsd
la DGSE donc vraiment augmentation des
effectifs mais là aussi on a ouvert 1500
postes mais on n'arrive pas à remplir
les 1500 postes et les 1500 postes quand
vous les avez ouvert il faut éviter que
les autres s'en aille pour éviter que
les autres s'en aillent il faut les
fidéliser et quand vous voulez fidéliser
quelqu'un qui a 10 ans d'ancienneté qui
est un analyse performant qui a 10 ans
d'ancienneté en matière de renseignement
et qui va être chassé par le monde civil
si vous voulez le fidéliser vous pouvez
pas le fidéliser avec son salaire avec
sa sonne c'est pas possible parce que en
général ils sont aspirés par par le
privé et ils sont inspirés avec des
salaires doublés voire triplés donc il
faut trouver autre chose donc l'idée
même d'imaginer qu'on puisse avoir une
réserve un peu spéciale dans le domaine
du renseignement pour conserver des gens
il faut souvent trois ans pour former un
analyste de les garder ensuite c'est
tout à fait intéressant sur le
satellitaire sur le satellitaire il y a
des secteurs sur lesquels on est on a
tellement choisi d'investir et de
manière performante je pense notamment
aux renseignement d'origine
électromagnétique qu'on est sans doute
dans le top 3 mondial on fait des
efforts énormes en matière satellitaire
on fait des efforts sur la captation
d'image donc on fait dans l'écoute on
fait des efforts donc avec syracus avec
CRS et donc tous ces éléments avec CSO
tous ces éléments concourent à augmenter
notre capacité à écouter à connaître à
anticiper et c'est évidemment un élément
important d'ailleurs la future LPM c'est
plus 60% de crédit dans le matière dans
le domaine du renseignement voilà merci
merci
merci alors on va essayer de répondre il
y a eu beaucoup beaucoup de questions
donc on va essayer de rassembler
j'espère que on pourra on pourra faire
le tour si jamais je pense qu'on pourra
faire un dernier question et un dernier
tour vous nous direz qu'on a oublié des
éléments
si j'ai eu on a une question sur le
comme cyber je crois
madame c'était vous
alors là on a quelques recommandations
effectivement on a permettez-moi
l'expression mille paquets sur cette sur
cette défense là malheureusement il y a
encore un problème et c'est toujours le
même problème le problème du recrutement
et de la fidélisation
l'objectif en termes de recrutement n'a
été atteint nous a dit le comme cyberk à
hauteur de 82%. donc c'est compliqué
c'est compliqué pour des raisons
salariales ou effectivement les salaires
proposés ne sont pas
attractifs pour des raisons de formation
et de valorisation des métiers c'est ce
qu'on voit dans ce secteur là comme on
le voit dans beaucoup le fait que nos
armées de plus en plus techniques de
plus en plus pointues de plus en plus
professionnel rentrent en concurrence
directe avec le privé et parfois même
d'ailleurs avec la BITD et donc on a un
problème c'est à dire qu'on prend des
jeunes on les engage on les forme
pendant trois ans ils sont mais ils sont
aguerris on va dire à la défense cyber
et bien évidemment le privé arrive le
ramène des salaires avec lesquels nous
ne pouvons pas lutter donc nous les avez
formés nous les laissons parler tir dans
la nature les les solutions sur ce
problème là parce que c'est
essentiellement une question humaine en
la matière sont celles qu'on a évoqué la
question évidemment du salaire la
question de la formation la question de
l'accompagnement de carrière de la
visibilité de carrière autant de points
qui sont selon nous à améliorer
aujourd'hui améliorer parce que nous ne
sommes pas seulement là pour investir
dans des jeunes recrues qui deviendront
des professionnels dans le privé mais
aussi parce que une fois que quelqu'un a
travaillé pour la défense cyber il
connaît un certain nombre de choses et
le traitement de cette personne une fois
qu'elle est dans la nature elle aussi
requiert des moyens et de l'attention je
serai pas plus précis mais vous voyez à
peu près ce que je veux dire et donc
là c'est un vrai point de vigilance
alors les choses se mettent en place les
[Musique]
responsables en sont tout à fait
conscients mais c'est un point sur
lequel on doit travailler sinon on n'y
arrivera pas voilà il faut il faut être
clair
d'une manière générale pour continuer
sur sur les les ressources humaines
c'est le décalage qui est mal vécu le
décalage entre des infrastructures hyper
techniques et hypermodennes pour les
moyens capacitaires et le décalage avec
des
investissements locatifs ou dans
l'hébergement qui ne sont pas adaptés en
fait il y a aussi une question sur le
SID il faut qu'on pose et que le SID je
crois se pose lui-même
il y a une compétence dans
l'architecture l'organisation la
préparation de bâtiments et
d'infrastructures militaires cette
compétence il faut évidemment la
maintenir mais est-ce que le SID est
simplement j'allais dire l'architecte le
concepteur et qu'on donne la réalisation
à des entreprises privées ou est-ce que
on maintient la filière de A à Z en
interne bon à titre personnel je suis
plutôt pour la deuxième proposition on a
pu visiter j'ai pu visiter à Brest des
locaux qui étaient des locaux de bureau
alors on peut se dire bon bah oui c'est
un local de bureau finalement
Vinci Bouygues ou je ne sais qui peuvent
le faire très bien sauf que évidemment
ce ne sont pas des bureaux comme les
autres son des bureaux qui doivent être
imperméables aux tentatives d'espionnage
qui doivent correspondre à des normes de
de sécurité de vigilance qui ne sont pas
celles de bâtiments publics classiques
donc il faut revoir je crois très
précisément le rôle du SID il
retravailler parce que aujourd'hui on
s'aperçoit que à la fois sur ce type de
bâtiment très technique sur des
infrastructures qui arrivent trop en
retard par rapport au matériel qui est
livré et sur l'hébergement du quotidien
et bien il y a des points de vigilance à
avoir donc je pense que là aussi il y a
un travail de fond
à faire sur les programmes
internationaux bon je ne vous cache pas
qu'on est globalement d'accord avec mon
corps rapporteur sur beaucoup de choses
sur celui-là on a
on partage un certain nombre je veux pas
parler en son nom mais on partage un
certain nombre de
poids mais voilà moi mon analyse et là
pour le coup elle met elle met
personnelle mais je l'évoque avec vous
c'est que on sait engouffré dans un
certain nombre de programmes
internationaux pas par nécessité mais
par envie diplomatique et envie
d'affichage voilà on va sous on va
sauver le couple franco-allemand et en
général dans un couple faux avec deux à
vouloir être un couple j'ai l'impression
qu'on est seul mais bref et on va
travailler sur le SCAF et puis on serait
on se rend compte au fur et à mesure que
on n'a pas forcément les mêmes objectifs
que on n'a pas forcément les mêmes
moyens à mettre en place et qu'on n'a
pas forcément les mêmes intérêts
industriels nous par exemple sur le
Scaff on a besoin d'un avion qui puisse
décoller depuis un porter avion vous
imaginez bien que ça dit pas grand chose
à l'Allemagne
l'Allemagne elle est plus intéressée par
pouvoir transporter des ogives
américaines bon évidemment ça veut dire
qu'on n'est pas forcément exactement sur
le même
objectif c'est aussi une forme je lui
dis de naïveté de la part de la France
je crois que nous sommes sincères dans
notre volonté de coopération
je ne partagerai pas complètement cette
analyse sur l'Allemagne qui elle a
plutôt des ambitions industrielles
allemandes on peut pas lui en vouloir
d'ailleurs donc ce que nous proposons
est là pour le coup nous nous rejoignons
c'est qu'il y ait des étapes prédéfinies
des points d'étape régulier à chaque
étape ça va de la définition des
objectifs à la conception puis à la
réalisation où on puisse mettre en place
le plan B c'est à dire que si vraiment
ça marche pas avec l'Allemagne on va pas
perdre 10 ans parce que au bout d'un
moment on n'a pas assez dix ans on va
pas perdre de l'argent pour rien et bien
il faudra donner le bébé à Dassault par
exemple en tout cas des entreprises
françaises et ça pose la question de la
souveraineté je répondrai à Franck
Giletti sur ce point il faut que nos
industries de défense française aident
la visibilité
et de la visibilité elle peut pas
fonctionner par à coup quand une chaîne
de construction est démontée elle est
démontée et il faut des années pour la
reconstruire quand un salarié n'est pas
engagé sur une technicité précise on
perd un savoir-faire et ça met du temps
à retrouver et donc il faut non
seulement privilégier la vérité des
Françaises en premier lieu à défaut
européenne
mais surtout lui donner un carnet de
commande prévisible ce qui a
probablement manqué dans les années
précédentes où on a un peu fonctionné
par à coup on a la chance d'avoir une
première LPM qui a été fluide
relativement fluide une deuxième qui
s'annonce ce qui donne une préparation
puis une visibilité sur pratiquement 10
ans et donc c'est une chance historique
pour notre BITD pour la renforcer
pour aller sur des domaines où nous où
l'on n'était pas et pour se sécuriser
par rapport à des coopérations qui
pourraient parfois pas toujours parfois
être un peu aléatoire ou
contre-productive
il y avait beaucoup de questions donc je
voudrais pas trop pour n'oublier ce que
vous pouvez
alors
on y va
je vais retrouver
voilà
alors le MCO d'abord sur le MCO il faut
reconnaître que l'effort financier qui a
été prévu a été
respecté
c'était 23 milliards on les a eu et
c'est là aussi une première et
l'aéronautique qui était probablement le
domaine le plus
demandeur a été je dirais bien servi
il faudrait effectivement sur les MCO
aéronautique notamment une réforme de la
gouvernance avec la mise en place de la
direction de la maintenance aéronautique
une modification de la stratégie
et puis de manière générale sur
l'entraînement de nos équipes on s'est
aperçu quand même d'un certain nombre de
décalages par exemple on nous parle
beaucoup de la simulation bon moi je
suis perplexe je pense que rien ne vaut
l'entraînement réel mais surtout les
logiciels de simulation sont parfois en
décalage avec le non mais dans certaines
mesures évidemment
mais les logiciels de simulation étaient
en décalage complet avec le matériel
reçu bon c'est à dire que c'est une
simulation mais c'est parfois un
simulacre donc il faut là dessus en
termes de munition en termes de moyens
redonner aussi les moyens et en termes
de simulation être un peu plus
un peu plus affûté effectivement le fait
d'être en OPEX n'autorise pas aussi un
certain nombre de nos personnels à
s'entraîner c'est je crois là aussi un
des domaines de vigilance qu'on doit
pouvoir avoir sur la précédente
LPM je pense que l'entraînement le MCO
en général la disponibilité des
matériels qu'ils soient pour l'opération
ou pour l'entraînement doit être
améliorée j'ai une question aussi je
crois sur le la rénovation du matériel
là encore on peut prendre l'exemple des
mirages qui sont
rénovés à mi-vy comme on dit il y en a
55 de disponibles alors ami vie c'est
pas vrai puisque c'est à 2/3 de vie en
fait ils sont censés terminer leur
service en 2035 je crois que personne
n'y croit voilà personne n'y croit parce
que le tour afal ne sera pas prêt et que
donc c'est avions qui sont en cours de
réflexion qui sont livrés petit à petit
rénovés ces mirages devront durer très
probablement un peu plus longtemps et
donc il y aura une période où il y aura
une cohabitation des mirages et des
rafales et très honnêtement je crois
qu'il faut s'y préparer c'est à dire le
tour rafale qui a été annoncé par le
président de la République est un
objectif mais
à très moyen très voir long terme et que
ce serait une folie d'arrêter de rénover
nos aéronefs actuels en attendant la
livraison des rafales et qu'il faut pour
prendre un terme à la mode un tuilage
entre les deux et que donc on aura bien
besoin de ce matériel rénové il faut
passer des je crois à une volonté de la
communication sur la modernisation et ne
pas jeter l'ancien matériel tant que nos
personnels ne sont pas entraînés que les
livraisons n'ont pas eu lieu que les
simulateurs n'ont pas été adaptés que
les munitions qui peuvent être conjointe
au nouveau matériel non pas été livré là
aussi ça peut arriver je pense qu'il
faut pas chasser la proie pour l'ombre
qu'est-ce qu'on a d'autre
c'est bon j'ai fini pardon j'ai fini
alors il nous reste encore 3 minutes
pour égaliser les temps de parole et je
passe par là merci il y a une première
question sur les coopérations
européennes c'est un point évidemment
sur lequel on a on n'est pas tout à fait
en phase moi je suis évidemment
incroyant de la coopération à l'échelle
d'un d'un ensemble qui s'il se mettait
d'accord serait une puissance colossale
l'Union européenne en termes de crédit
affecté la défense et autant que les
États-Unis on n'a pas conscience on a
absolument pas conscience que
l'industrie de défense européenne c'est
une industrie d'une puissance
incroyable les chantiers qui
construisent des bateaux j'en passe mais
on a évidemment toujours nos modes de
fonctionnement qui sont les modes de
fonctionnement où on dit
on veut on veut et ajuste titre
conserver dans certains secteurs je
pense je sais pas moi la cellule d'un
avion ou tel une capacité et c'est juste
et c'est juste sauf que quand on est
vraiment sur les programmes de
coopération on arrive aussi à voir des
effets de masse qui font chuter les
coûts
on a pris un peu de retard c'est vrai il
y a eu un temps de blocage sur
mgcs escaf mais c'est terminé les
déclarations du président de la
République et du chancelier allemand à
l'occasion des 60 ans de du traité de
l'Élysée était très claire donc de ce
côté-là on avance
il y a ensuite une question qui a été
posée sur
l'interopérabilité c'est toi qui a posé
cette question oui oui ça marche et ça
marche bien et ça a marché tout de suite
ce qui est important c'est de comprendre
que quand on s'y met tous ensemble on
est redoutable
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé au moment du
début du conflit vous aviez cinq
portes-avions 5 porte-avions à la mer au
début du conflit ukrainien je parle même
pas des trois sous-marins nucléaires
dans un français lanceur dans un
français qui pour la première fois
depuis été à la mer en même temps c'est
un signal très fort quand même il y
avait cinq porte-avions ça voulait pas
dire qu'il y avait cinq groupes
aéronavales constitué tous de bâtiments
appartenant tous au même nation pour par
exemple le groupe aéronaval français
autour du Charles de Gaulle et ben il y
avait des frégates il y avait un certain
nombre de bâtiments qui n'était pas des
bâtiments français ça j'allais dire
c'est
interopérabilité opérationnelle mais ça
demande de l'entraînement forcément
donc ça c'est le premier élément le
deuxième évidemment quelqu'un posé la
question en disant il y a moins on
s'entraîne moins
oui c'est vrai on s'entraîne moins parce
qu'il y a plus de missions
mais pour le coup vous pensez pas que
quand on est en mission on s'entraîne
bien aussi parce qu'on est vraiment dans
le dur donc voilà on est aujourd'hui à
la croisée des chemins on a une loi de
programmation militaire qui est en cours
d'exécution quelqu'un évoquait tout à
l'heure la cible 2025 en disant la cible
elle est pas forcément atteinte attendez
attendons d'avoir terminé et vous
connaissez le principe c'est toujours la
fin du bal qu'il faut payer les
musiciens et pas avant donc
attendons 25 on va tuer avec le futur
LPM les moyens qui ont été engagés sont
des moyens incroyables n'oubliez pas
qu'en 2017 quand on construit la LPM il
y a pas de conflit en Europe on est sur
des opérations et des projections dans
le Sahel on n'a pas les guerres
d'influence que nous connaissons
aujourd'hui on mesure pas complètement
l'importance du du fait satellitaire
parce qu'on a aussi des soutiens bien de
puissance
qui ne sont pas des puissants qui ne
sont pas la France aujourd'hui le saut
ce que nous avons réalisé est énorme et
tout ça prépare le socle de la future
LPM n'oubliez pas que quand vous êtes
une puissance mondiale et quand je dis
puissance mondiale je le dis vraiment à
dessin moi j'ai repris les propos de la
première de la mise d'affaires
étrangères australienne il y a pas très
longtemps qui était au Quai d'Orsay et
ça nous paraît tellement loin le
Pacifique qu'est-ce qu'elle a dit
écoutez bien vraiment moi ça m'a frappé
la France est une puissance mondiale
premièrement membre du P5 deuxièmement
une puissance nucléaire
membres du G7 essentiel à l'Union
européenne et une puissance de
l'Indopacifique voilà non
responsabilités l'Indopacifique c'est
sans doute pour les années qui viennent
avec la montée d'un certain nombre
d'Empire qui sont en train de se
reconstituer pas forcément dans
l'adopacifique mais plus près de chez
nous aussi ce sont les enjeux de demain
n'oubliez pas que la France c'est 11
millions de kilomètres carrés zone
économique exclusive c'est une puissance
maritime majeure vraiment une dernière
intervention très vite parce qu'il y a
des questions auxquelles on n'a pas
répondu madame picwi il y a une question
sur l'inflation et oui une de nos
propositions c'est comme nous l'avons
dit de prendre cet élément en compte
pour éviter les les conséquences
la cannibalisation de Monsieur bocaletti
oui c'est vrai c'est vrai notamment sur
les chars c'est très important et là
aussi ça met en question la politique de
BITD et
à qui j'ai pas répondu madame Bazin
malgrat
ouais il y a pas eu de plainte pour être
très honnête il y a pas eu de plainte
sur l'envoi de matériel a eu des
constats sur les retards que ça pouvait
engendrer sur les difficultés que ça
pouvait engendrer et l'impact sur nos
matériels qui pouvaient être manquants
mais il y a pas eu de pleines c'est
sûrement dû au caractère des militaires
qui ne sont pas du genre à se plaindre
mais ça avait été
évoqué
à qui d'autre est-ce qu'on a pas répondu
rapidement on voudrait pas faire de
frustré
tu voulais
ah très honnêtement là sur l'état oui
nations
le lien armée nation pour être pour être
très honnête
dans cette LPM même si le recours au
réserviste c'est un peu accéléré qu'on
prévoit un doublement très honnêtement
ça n'a pas été un élément structurant
cet LPM on peut être très clair il y a
beaucoup de travail à faire sur les
réservistes qui sont peu des marchés
dans des conditions peu attractives
parfois qui sont parfois laiss de beauté
donc tout le monde en est conscient il y
a un effort à faire et probablement sur
l'implication des jeunes et c'est la
question qui télécharge je crois du SNU
je sais qu'il on y travaille c'est
parallèle à la LPM mais il y a un vrai
boulot à faire on parlait de
fidélisation c'est vrai que quand on
considère l'armée comme un job comme un
autre c'est pas très bon parce que ce
qui fait qu'un militaire est attaché à
l'armée c'est l'esprit patriotique c'est
le sentiment d'appartenir à cette élite
défensive qu'elle l'armée c'est pas
simplement la feuille de paye même si
c'est important merci beaucoup de
rapporteurs bien entendu on peut pas
traiter dans le détail l'intégralité des
sujets sur le soutien militaire à
l'Ukraine il y aura par exemple sans
doute une mission d'information qui
abordera spécifiquement ce sujet dans
les mois qui arrivent en tout cas merci
beaucoup pour la qualité de votre
travail qui nous prépare utilement et
collectivement aux échéances à venir
parce que je pense que même si on
partage pas tout à fait les mêmes
options on a la responsabilité de de se
rassembler pour notre défense nationale
pour la loi de programmation militaire
qui arrive mes chers collègues je vais
vous demander maintenant si vous
autorisez la publication de ce rapport
forme est-ce qu'il y a des oppositions
des abstentions je n'en vois pas et donc
on vous remercie messieurs j'appelle
maintenant les deux co-rapportunteurs
Jean-Louis Thériault et Natalia pouziree
pour la mission suivante
puisque je vous propose d'enchaîner
directement